this is great guys I'm so excited to
play Dungeons & Dragons for the first
time excellent
so in this game you can do anything you
want you have complete free will okay I
love it open-ended okay let's set the
scene XANA dong Elric
Thaddeus you enter an old tavern in the
town of Belding you see a table near the
fireplace the far wall and seated beside
it is a wizard holding an orb he's
speaking strange incantations into it
what would you like to do okay I enter
the tavern yes I get a table on the
opposite end of the room is the wizard
so far away from him I would like to be
as far away from the wizard as possible
okay because there are tables near him
that are completely open I don't want to
talk to old weird men talking to orbs
okay look the wizard appears before your
table and sits down with the three of
you okay that's weird
because for all he knows we're waiting
for a fourth he he's a little offended
but then he says listen to the tale of
the ogre of kaga he's coming on a little
strong so I stand up says where are you
going say none of your business it
wasn't just stop it stop doing that he
said I could do anything but this is an
open-ended game yes Pete maybe we should
talk to the wizard you can send us on a
quest I'm in two quests I'm a quest kind
of guy okay I just don't want to quest
on an empty stomach
so I asked to look at a menu okay the
tavern wench comes over and she was
tavern wench she's in her 40s how's her
body it's good nice what's good here
m'lady she says I don't the mutton I
would love the mutton maybe we should do
something a little more adventurous more
adventurous Eileen in real clothes yes
give me the eggplant parm how is that
adventurous six times out of seven it
gives Miriah Korea diarrhea there's no
she says there's no eggplant parm
of course there wouldn't
B it is a Dark Age economy so why would
that even be in this then I'll have the
mutton fine so we had you have your
mutton okay can we just please can we
take it seriously now okay all right
okay I reach down to the cold handle of
my steel it blaze yes your ever blade of
Frost and I remove it from its sheath
yes everyone looks in your direction and
they watch me as I cut my mutton into
smaller more digestible pieces okay you
know what screw it I go up to the wizard
thank you I am Trish from the wise man
of this village my orb has shown me an
ogre dwelling in the shallow arches I
need you to go on a quest to stop him I
accept this quest I to accept Zanna Don
we are going on a mighty quest will you
join us I need to get some shut-eye
sleep off the mutton and then I'm gonna
ask if there's an inn attached to this
tavern there isn't in a D&D B&B sure
Dungeons and Dragons and beds and
breakfasts yes okay I'll get a room okay
the other two Warriors set off on their
quest Elric the ogre roars you can smell
its breath and then it attacks you with
stone fist it's a hit I counter with
disruptive strike success are you storm
a thousand blades yes yes I just kind of
walk into my hotel really you know just
kind of like soak in the body okay so
I'm gonna soak in all right you don't
even have to roll you rolled and okay
see you successfully soaked in the vibe
great I wanna kick off my weird boots
and just kind of get in there
very good all right the ogre uses
thunder - on the two of you who are in
the adventure and it is a critical hit
and I am dead me too
game ogre are you guys go Gert Kelly so
game ogre I'm gonna go yeah all right
thanks so much Ari I'm also gonna do
yeah thanks for playing guys it's not
normally like this the game is different
all right looks like it's just me and
you Dungeon Master okay Pete so you're
the only adventurer left alive so what
would you like to do I would like to go
on an adventure
downstairs okay I'm going to talk to
that winch I want to make it happen that
mutton was dry let's see if anything's
moist nah mean by what happens with me
in the serving winch figure it out I
don't need you I go up to the wench oh
if you roll over a ten I'll let you do
BUTT STUFF
really woo I'm going downtown to
Browntown this games fun